yep that is liquid corn hi I'm Vicki and
I try new things today I'll be trying to
make the sweet corn coffee from Singles
Inferno for the first time I'm just
going to assume what it tastes like I'm
going to use the sweet corn oh wow we
match and condensed
milk this is how it currently looks
like after blending I strained the
mixture then I made my coffee I'm just
using instant coffee it's just full
finally got around to using this ice
tray that I've been seeing all over Tik
Tok first I pour it in the corn mixture
then the foam I mean coffee here's my
filled attemp at putting an espresso
bear
in I tasted corn an espresso a little
too sweet but not bad